Tyler Perry is taking over a role
formerly played by Morgan Freeman whose
idea was that hey Chris are you wearing
a Pikachu shirt yes as a matter of fact
I am and that is why you should listen
to everything I'm about to say Alex
Cross is directed by Rob Cohen the man
who brought us the Fast and the Furious
xxx stealth and the mummy tomb of the
Dragon Emperor it stars Tyler Perry as a
character of dr. Alex Cross
Matthew Fox as a crazy psychopath
villain rachel nichols and edward burns
as fellow cops basically Matthew Fox is
this whacked-out insane guy who's on
this mission you don't really know what
he's doing he's just killing a lot of
people Tyler Perry and Edward Burns
Rachel Nichols these are detectives who
are on his trail trying to figure out
where he is trying to stop him from
murdering certain people and Tyler Perry
is sniffing him out he is like the
detective of all detectives he knows
where everything is he can figure it out
he's one of those guys like Sherlock
Holmes he walks into a room and he goes
yes this was this way this was that way
this is where he's going this what he
wants to do and I know everything and I
am basically God no you're not God
Morgan Freeman was God and he played
Alex Cross before you yes now I'm not
really a Tyler Perry fan I don't have
anything against the man at all I just
I'm not a fan of the Mahdi in movies
I've never reviewed them in fact I've
never seen them so I can't really say
I'm not a fan of them because I've never
seen them but I just know that I am NOT
a fan of him even though I haven't seen
them I know I wasn't really looking
forward to seeing this movie with the
director generally creating very
mediocre Hollywood action entertainment
and Tyler Perry just not really fitting
into this world and yeah yeah it sucks
it's actually awful I really hated this
movie Alex Cross is one of the worst
movies I've seen all year and I'll tell
you why um everything about it doesn't
work unfortunately it's a movie that
tries to blend very very special effects
II CGI action with heartfelt family
drama along with this mystery this
murder mystery and none of it works
let's talk about the more heartfelt
aspects of this film the fan
drama the tension it is so sappy and
melodramatic I cannot even begin to
describe it to you you just have to see
it it is so fake this is such a
production it's like okay we're going to
create this really heartfelt scene it's
gonna be a lot of Tears and
father-daughter bonding and love and
wonderful caring moments and it's just
so poorly done that it feels like an
after-school soap opera or something it
doesn't work in this movie because
there's this whole other side to it it's
this really dark and gruesome murder
film with Matthew Fox as this
whacked-out like basically coke fiend I
mean I don't know how else to explain
the way he acts they never show him do
drugs but he might as well be and the
action side of this film is even worse
than the emotional side of it it is
filmed so poorly
I thought the fight scenes in taken - or
bad I'm not exaggerating I yearned for
the fight scenes have taken to the fight
scenes in this movie implores the worst
shaky-cam
I maybe have ever seen in my life
because shaky-cam is actually an art
form you know sometimes it's used as
this gimmick that just doesn't work but
it actually is an art form that can be
used successfully in films like say
Saving Private Ryan or the Bourne films
here it's not shaky-cam like we're going
to make this look gritty there's the guy
the cameraman is actually shaking the
camera that's all he's doing during
these fight scenes is he's just shaking
it back and forth up and down and you
cannot tell what's going on I swear all
it is is a barrage of movements and
blurs of things with sound effects if
those sound effects were not there you
would have no clue what's happening this
movie has the worst fight scene of the
year worst fight scene probably of last
year - I'm serious it is so terrible
there is no direction to the camera it
just flows around and you're supposed to
try to focus on certain objects there is
no composure to the shots whatsoever the
direction is so boring and cliched and
the script I'm telling you guys it's
just it's so stupid there are two pluses
to this movie and let me try to explain
- because they're actually bolts but
they're pluses in a certain way I can
tell that Tyler Perry and Matthew Fox
are actually trying very hard it's just
that the film is not in any way up to
the desires of these two actors who are
trying to do something and because of
that it becomes comical their
performances it's a joke Matthew Fox's
performance in this movie he's trying so
hard to give a good performance and he
altered his body and everything and this
movie is just bad it's one of the worst
films I've seen all year I'm giving it a
d-plus simply because these actors are
trying it's just not working out just
don't see this movie if you haven't seen
it yet go see sinister or Seven
Psychopaths or Argo or The Perks of
Being a Wallflower or looper or
something anything just don't see this
movie please don't pay them money just
know thanks a lot for watching guys and
as always if you liked this review then
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes